[Musique]
bonjour à vis de vous retrouver ici
depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble les portes
de l'europe
et voici le programme trente ans après
la chute du mur de berlin les stigmates
du passé sont ils effacent et l'europe
alors riche de promesses ce 9 novembre
1989 at-elle depuis réussi à rassembler
nous nous sommes rendus à berlin et vous
verrez que chez certains l'espoir
européen a fait place au ressentiment et
aux doutes ouvrirons le débat avec nos
invités en plateau mais avant tout ce
qu'il ne fallait pas louper dans
l'actualité européenne cette semaine
élection présidentielle en roumanie
élections législatives en espagne lindt
avoue d'ayman al macron dans six
économistes c'est résumé pour vous par
aurélie la face
[Musique]
emmanuel macron critiquent la règle
communautaire des 3%
dans une interview accordée au magazine
britannique the economist le président
français considèrent que la règle
limitant le déficit budgétaire à 3% du
pib est un débat d'un autre siècle
le chef de l'état plaide pour une
politique d'investissement active en
europe
il a notamment appelé les allemands
partisans de l'orthodoxie budgétaire a
considéré que la situation actuelle
n'est pas durable
un pro européen en tête de l'élection
présidentielle en roumanie dit le
libéral claus ioannis obtient plus de
36% des suffrages son parti confirme
ainsi la dynamique enclenchée lors des
européennes au mois de mai où il était
arrivé en tête ce premier tour de
scrutin accentue la déroute du ps d un
parti qui a pourtant dominé la vie
politique roumaine ces trente dernières
années le gouvernement social-démocrate
de viorica d'annecy la a été renversé le
mois dernier et elle peine aujourd'hui à
se hisser au second tour de la
présidentielle avec seulement 24 % des
voix quatrièmes élections législatives
en quatre ans en espagne le premier
ministre sortant pedro sanchez remporté
le scrutin mais ne résout pas ses
difficultés à former un gouvernement
avec 120 députés
les socialistes sont loin de la majorité
absolue des 176 sièges
il devance le parti populaire partie de
la droite espagnole
les élections sont marquées par la
percée de l'extrême droite avec 52
sièges le parti box double son score
d'avril et devient la troisième force
politique du pays
[Musique]
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir domenech
ruiz dv ça vous êtes membre du groupe
des socialistes et démocrates ici au
parlement européen depuis mai dernier
bonjour ce que brut il retenir de ces
élections législatives en espagne arrivé
en tête des socialistes votre famille
politique ou bien la percée très forte
de vox le parti d'extrême droite qui
devient la troisième force politique du
pays
bon c'est vrai qu'elle est parti
socialiste a gagné les élections
c'est clair que la seule possibilité
d'avoir un gouvernement en espagne c'est
avec nos la participation les
leaderships de questions subsistent
retenez de ces élections ça c'est la
première conclusion la deuxième
conclusion c'est que selon moi la la
montée de boxe du parti d'extrême-droite
et d'y monter dépenses est plutôt
conjoncturel il ya encore un an à
l'espagne était l'un des rares pays
européens à ne compter aucun parti
d'extrême droite ou par le monde et
c'est le résultat des derniers
événements que nous avons vécu en
catalogne
l'essai mais la piste catalane avec la
montée du parti d'extrême droite
week-end oui oui oui parce que vraiment
en espagne il n'y a pas beaucoup d des
sentiments politiques sur la question
migratoire par exemple ou sur la
question européenne anglais fait
souverainiste donc les soutiens à vox
explique notamment comme réaction de
douvier nationalisme espagnol contre
l'indépendantisme catalan il est alors
justement comment on sort de cette crise
catalan et comment on fait face à la
montée de vox
bon c'est là la question plus compliqué
parce que nous les socialistes on a
toujours se dire soutenu que pour
trouver une solution pour la crise
catalan il faut appliquer la loi bien
sûr mais aussi engagé politiquement avec
un dialogue mais par les moments
les champagnes dépend dentiste et
beaucoup radicaliser et ils se pensent
toujours qu'il faut peut-être utilisé de
voir mes latéraux ou unilatérale je veux
dire qu'il faut pas nécessairement
respecter les lois et la constitution
donc pour engager politiquement il faut
se mettre d'accord que tout dialogue
doit se dérouler dans l'es4
constitutionnel espagnol
on a assisté à des scènes de violence
mais aussi des manifestations
le mois dernier il ya eu un verdict très
durs à l'encontre de neuf dirigeants
indépendantistes chargé du référendum
d'indépendance
oui en 2017 oui comment du coup on
engage le dialogue avec les
indépendantistes catalans alors que eux
sont révoltés contre ce verdict oui mais
nous savons on peut négocier
nous avons en espagne en france en
europe qui est le pouvoir judiciaire est
indépendant
donc on peut on peut faire rien bon les
sentences wii sont durs mais on ne peut
pas dire en bon
comme nous avons c c
ces décisions du juge on ne peut pas
engager avec un dialogue politique c'est
pas la faute du gouvernement
vous avez besoin des indépendantistes
maintenant pour gouverner oui doit avoir
au minimum la lâcheté mention des
quelques partis indépendantistes
c'est nécessaire toujours comme jeudi a
engagé dans un dialogue
je pense qu'il ya des choses qu'on ne
peut se mettre d'accord par exemple sur
quoi bon catalogne pour p avoir bien
jour un cadre dans l'espagne différents
dindane les cadiens est
inconstitutionnelle on peut réformer la
constitution régional de la catalogne un
statut différent donc de la catalogne
oui oui des dents l'espagne est pour ça
dans l'unité espagnole dans le cadre
d'un espagnol c'est possible les partis
socialistes et a proposé d' effet de
réaliser et l'état déjà autonomie est de
revoir le financement parce que beaucoup
de gens pensent que quand catalogne le
traitement fiscal c'est pas c'est pas
juste
donc il ya beaucoup à faire dans ce oui
mais vous êtes évidemment un fermement
opposée à l'indépendance puis au delà de
tout cela les cartes politiques est ce
qu'elles sont complètement rebattu en
espagne delà de la forte progression de
vox il y à aussi l'effondrement des
centristes sur les parties si danone a
eu l'opportunité de nous soutenir et en
gouvernement qui pouvaient avoir la
majorité absolue du parlement et sans
dépendre des partis indépendantistes et
nationalistes et pour mener des réformes
pour se mettre d'accord sur l'économie
et avec beaucoup de positions communes
sur l'europe par examen et ils ont
refusé et absolument des négociateurs
nous et je pense que les jeunes au space
hésitation oui oui suite aux résultats
ils ont passé de 57 à 10 tout à fait
c'est une chute extraordinaire suite aux
résultats 1 sortie des urnes pedro
sanchez le socialiste a formé donc à
trouver un accord de principe avec le
leader de podemos pour y former un
gouvernement de coalition
mais cela ne suffit pas alors avec qui
peuvent-ils gouverner et trouver une
majorité
bon nous avons la possibilité de faire
cette gouvernement avec le soutien des
pots demos à cela on peut ajouter des
partis régionalistes qui ne sont pas
indépendantiste il faut avoir aussi au
moins l'abstention de quelques groupes
indépendantistes c'est pas facile hein
c'est vrai mais on va essayer parce que
on a besoin d'un gouvernement
progressiste et non pas on parlait
encore une fois les élections
merci dominique rizet vayssade est
revenu sur notre plateau et on passe un
tout autre sujet ce jeudi 9 novembre
1989 reste à jamais un moment historique
celui de la chute du mur entre les deux
allemagnes entre les deux europe celle
de l'ouest et celles de l'est
trente ans après que reste-t-il de cette
frontière les plaies sont elles
définitivement penser notre reporter
béatrice faisant s'est rendu à berlin
et il ya parfois de la nostalgie dans
l'air
il est tombé il y a trente ans le mur de
berlin une séparation est ouest de la
ville mais aussi du pays
une cicatrice encore présente dans la
mémoire des allemands est toujours
visible dans la capitale
dans les rues de la ville européenne
certains cherchent l'inspiration harald
oswald à photographier toute sa vie les
aussi ces allemands de l'est dont il
fait partie témoin précieux d'une époque
encore douloureuse
ils continuent de capturer l'âme de
l'est avait un regard personnel sur la
situation
une vision critique face aux
circonstances de l'époque je me suis
senti enfermé en rda car il n'y avait
aucune liberté et la pression politique
était très forte
la photographie a été pour moi l'unique
moyen d'exprimer mon désaccord
un désaccord mais surtout une critique
du système politique alors en place
comme sur cette photographie qui montre
des enfants jouant sur un tas de ruines
dans un quartier totalement laissée à
l'abandon à l'image de tout l'est de
berlin
c'est d'ailleurs ici à prenzlauer berg
caral d'oswald vivait berceau du courant
artistique de l'époque un milieu
contestataires qui attendait comme tous
les allemands beaucoup de la
réunification c'est green ce chineur ça
a été trop rapide et trop radicales ce
n'était pas une réunification l'ouest
ces juges jeter sur l'est l'ouest a
écrasé les dragons club comme bordeaux
une annexion plus qu'une réunification
dans l'esprit de nombreux allemands
pourtant il y à 40 ans ce couple
n'aurait jamais pu se rencontrer lui
vient de l'ouest et elle de l'est à eux
deux ils symbolisent l'idée d'une nation
retrouver bernanke m nous avons un
enfant lui c'est vraiment le parfait
résultat de la réunification
il mêle ce qu'il y a de mieux des deux
côtés la loyauté et la fidélité de l'est
l'ambition et la détermination de
l'ouest at-il sigrist auto spécisme une
vision heureuse de la réunification
pourtant les disparités demeurent
il y à 16 ans le couple se retrouve
contraint de quitter le centre de berlin
devenu trop coûteux pour venir
s'installer ici à l'est de la capitale
dans le quartier de mark than fortement
marqué par l'urbanisme soviétique abrite
la première chose que l'on voit quand on
arrive
ce sont les barres d'immeubles si le
temps est bizarre ça donne une
impression de fin du monde
nous n'avons pas choisi d'habiter à
amman en 2012 quand les loyers ont
explosé c'était impossible de trouver
autre chose
nous étions à la rue pendant trois mois
et ici à matane c'était le seul
appartements disponibles que nous avons
réussi à avoir signé
ici il y a toujours des airs de rda et
le tram jaune en est le témoin se trame
que l'on retrouve dans le centre de
berlin
à l'est seulement dans la ville les
stigmates de la séparation demeurent
jusque dans les feux de signalisation et
cette différence
l'alternative pour l'allemagne en a fait
son terreau à berlin le parti d'extrême
droite xénophobe a réalisé son meilleur
score justement à mark than
nous sommes bien implantés dans ce
quartier et notre victoire électorale le
démontre ce résultat est aussi dû au
fait que les habitants de l'ex
république fédérale allemande ne sont
pas venus s'installer ici
l'afd joue la carte de l'ex rda et
soeurs sur la nostalgie d'une époque où
la population est allemande vivait en
totale autarcie une population sacrifier
au moment de la réunification après la
chute du mur surtout à l'est
toutes les sociétés ont été détruites
toutes les sociétés ont fermé des
millions de personnes se sont retrouvées
au chômage meilleur pour réduire ce
déséquilibre présents notamment au sein
des administrations
certains politiques proposent la mise en
place de quotas pour l'afd
ce n'est pas la solution trahi ses
joueurs trente ans après la chute du mur
il y a toujours des différences
significatives entre les salaires les
retraites qui se démarque le long du mur
c'est là que le mur est encore visible
et c'est pour cette raison que la
réunification n'est pas encore réussi
tant que nous ne serons pas sur un pied
d'égalité au moins au niveau social on
ne pourra pas parler de réunification
réussi à placer un commando fans de
longue date
eux nous continuait de diviser la
population allemande comme il y a trente
ans l'argument n'a aucun sens selon
harald oswalt la réunification a bel et
bien eu lieu et berlin capitale
on est le meilleur symbole le retour de
berlin comme capitale de l'allemagne a
été une étape fondamentale dans le
processus de réunification le signe que
la ville s'ouvre est de nouveau monde
est apte à m
[Musique]
dont les rues de berlin est
harald oswalt s'arrête face à une scène
de vie banale que l'on pourrait voir
dans n'importe quelle autre ville
européenne
[Musique]
et j'accueille sur ce plateau rosa
tourner bonjour vous êtes au député
polonais elle depuis 2009 et vous
appartenait au groupe conservateur le
ppe anna cavadini vous êtes eurodéputés
à verte allemande depuis mai dernier
vous aussi bernard guetta vous avez été
élu en mai dernier sous la bannière
alejo m
vous êtes français et vous siégez ici au
sein du groupe renault
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet je
voulais savoir quels souvenirs vous
gardez de la chute du mur de berlin
anna cavadini vous avez sept ans
l'époque je crois qu'elles sont bien
regarder oui j'avais 7 ans mais quand
même je me souviens très bien parce que
la moitié de ma famille vécu en
allemagne de l'est
moi je suis né dans l'allemagne de l'est
de l'ouest et c'était vraiment difficile
de se voir avant et avec la chute du mur
c'était aussi un peu une réunification
de ma famille bernard guetta
j'étais à erevan la capitale de
l'arménie soviétique et je constate et
parce que je vais le correspondant du
monde à moscou à l'époque et je
constatais à erevan que après
l'éclatement du bloc soviétique qui
avait commencé non pas du tout en
novembre n'ont pas du tout le 9 novembre
mais au printemps en avant quand la
frontière à frontière les barbelés entre
l'autriche et la hongrie s'était ouvert
je constatais que on était entré dans le
processus de désintégration de l'union
soviétique
alors justement à l'occasion des 30 ans
à la chute du mur on a beaucoup parlé on
l'a vu également d'un reportage de
nostalgie de disparités économiques d'un
sentiment d'une europe à deux vitesses
de citoyens européens de seconde zone
à croire qu'on oublie quel soulagement
cela était il ya 30 ans vaut à thoune
bien sûr que c'était un soulagement
énorme et c'est toujours encore un
soulagement même si pas tout le monde le
comprend ou s'il y avait certains qui
ont oublié ou peut-être s'il ya des
jeunes qui n'ont jamais appris mais
c'est ça complètement et c'est pas
seulement c'est pas la chute du mur
juste sait-on bernard guetta vient de
dire ça a commencé bien plus tôt de la
pologne par exemple avait dès les
élections au mois de juin déjà dont on
voyait que ça
que sa bouille que le monde change que
l'europe change que que l'union
soviétique s'écroule c'était et c'est le
meilleur morceau de l'histoire
européenne de des bernardins car le
poids des mots il est important est ce
qu'on peut encore parler
c'est une vraie question de
l'unification d'intégration certains
parlent même d'une annexion je vous ai
vu réagira durant le reportage anna
camadini ont réécrit l'histoire là oui
je crois qu'on doit aller de la une
réunification il c'était un success ça
c'est clair parce qu'on a maintenant on
a gagné la liberté on a gagné la
démocratie et tout ça tout ça mais on
doit en même temps dire qu'il y avait
aussi quelques erreurs on a fait
peut-être accepté de dire que oui
peut-être c'est peut-être trop vite et
aussi quelques entreprises dans l'est de
l'allemagne n'était pas saoul vie et
c'est pour ça que beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes ont perdu son travail dans le
reportage c'est ce qu'exprime le
photographe quand ils disent là était
trop rapide trop radicales ce n'était
pas une réunification l'ouest s'est jeté
sur l'est l'ouest a écrasé l'est c'est
fort bernard guetta aux commentaires
c'est pas fort c'est extrêmement
choquant ce mot d'annexion révolte ça a
été repris par des hommes politiques en
france c'est à la mode en ce moment
nora écouter une annexion c'est l'entrée
de chars c'est l'entrée de forces
militaires dans un autre pays
c'est une annexion par la force
souvenons nous de ce qui s'est passé les
allemands de l'est ce manifesté par
centaines de milliers ensuite il y à la
transition économique et la transition
économie parsemé d'erreurs évidemment
forcément parsemé d'erreurs a été très
violente à mes yeux beaucoup trop
violente
mais est ce que c'est parce que cette
transition économique a été si violente
socialement parlant
premièrement qu'elle n'est pas une
réussite je suis désolé c'est une
réussite
il comprit expliqué quand même que seuls
38 % des allemands estiment que la
réunification est en sursis
moi je dirais aussi que ce mot invasion
rien jusqu'à 1
le mans c'est vraiment injuste c'est une
complète des incompréhensions et il faut
comprendre le temps le 89
elle semble dans le monde entier ne
savait comment sortir du système
communiste parce que cette expérience
personne n'a fait donc bien sûr qu'on
faisait les fautes
aussi n'est-ce pas qu'il ya eu des
erreurs c'est ça bien et je suis désolé
et pas seulement en allemagne de l'est
dans tous les pays de l'est on a commis
beaucoup d'erreurs alors qu'elle sait
pas trop quelles erreurs ont été
commises
on ne peut pas dire que politiquement ça
allait trop vite parce que qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire trop vite
n'est ce pas il ya des certains qui
disent ces pays sont entrés dans l'union
européenne
trop tôt qu'est ce que ça veut dire trot
est ce que ce serait possible
aujourd'hui
c'était extrêmement important pour
l'europe d'introduire le marché libre
d'ouvrir les frontières de se libérer de
la censure dans les médias 2
respecter les droits de l'homme et et
tout cela ces pays ont complètement
changé complètement changé et c'est vrai
que pour beaucoup de personnes
beaucoup de citoyens c'est très fatigant
c'est très difficile c'est pas tout le
monde est tellement des bruyères le
marché communiste est beaucoup plus
facile que le facile mais dur on a le
même temps parce qu'on est pauvre
normalement on était tous très pauvre
dans cette europe de l'est et le marché
libre demande une activité en aucun cas
les citoyens des pays communistes
n'étaient pas habitués etc etc
je crois que la libération économique
était trop vite à la réunification
politique mais la libération d'andreas
trop et trop vite
mais et on doit dire aussi les
révolutionnaires les mouvements sociaux
dans les airs d aoulef autres modèles
mais on doit aussi dire dans les
premières élections libres la moitié la
grande moitié de l'allemagne de l'est à
votre type unification très vite ils
voulaient pour les partis conservateurs
lui il voulait une progrès économique
très vite et ça fait légitime ça c'est
légitime mais peut-être depuis
aujourd'hui on peut dire peut-être
c'était une erreur c'était trop vite
mais la grande partie du peuple voulait
sortir de systèmes autoritaires
communiste dictature communiste c'est un
défi extrêmement difficile et justement
on n'a pas d'expérience on a pas
personne ne sait comment le faire donc
bien sûr qu'il y aller au les bas et
maintenant moi je crois vraiment au
sérieux c'était mon but
entrée dans l'union européenne quand on
va vraiment travailler sur les mêmes
standards de la démocratie état de droit
justement vous parlez de valeur vous
n'êtes pas né d'hier libre vous n'êtes
pas les seuls en ce que la chancelière
allemande à l'occasion de la
commémoration de la chute du mur de
berlin s'est rendu dans la chapelle de
la réconciliation où elle a prononcé un
discours je vous propose est bien de
l'écouter on réagit après sortie boîte
les valeurs sur lesquelles l'europe est
fondée la liberté la démocratie
l'égalité l'état de droit
le respect des droits de l'homme sont
tout sauf évidente et elles doivent
toujours être défendu anna cavani est ce
que ce sont ces valeurs qui rassemblent
aujourd'hui en 2019
les européens je crois que oui images as
me est d'accord avec le chant sierre qui
dit qu' ils sont pas évidents on doit le
défendre
jacques sourd et tous les jours tous les
jours parce que on sait de toute
l'europe il ya un tournant c'est
l'extrême droite qui est qu'ils veulent
au contraire et que veut vraiment que
l'europe changé et tout le corps à tout
ce qu'on a réussi à mettre des tweets la
séparation est ce qu'elle est pas là le
premier ministre viktor orban
il serait temps que lui mais ses alliés
du groupe devisera devise grade
je rappelle un groupe informel d'europe
centrale hongrie pologne république
tchèque slovaquie incarne la vraie
europe c'est-à-dire une europe
chrétienne fermement contre le
multiculturalisme et contre la
mondialisation alors comment on arrive à
se rassembler un grand malaise nous
avons tous les trois je crois un grand
malaise en face de monsieur orban et
réciproquement
est ce que ça signifie que l'union
européenne va éclater non
catégoriquement non et pour une raison
il n'y a pas un seul électeur je dis
bien pas un seul électeur de monsieur
obame qui souhaiteraient aujourd'hui que
la hongrie sorte de l'union
il n'y a pas un électeur de monsieur
kaczinsky en pologne qui souhaiteraient
que la pologne sorte de l'union
européenne
alors on a entendu angela merkel mais
emmanuel manichon qui a donné une
interview à the economist dans lequel il
dit notamment que l'union européenne
elle est au bord du précipice car au
fond il s'est vu avant tout comme un
marché et non plus comme un projet
politique
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
constat du président français ce n'est
pas un projet par litre seulement
économique ce marché commun c'est
extrêmement important
mais son sens politique commune le
marché ne va pas fonctionner non plus à
vrai dire le la motivation pour laquelle
énormément de nos citoyens ont voté oui
dans le référendum quand on entrait dans
l'union européenne était la démocratie
étaient ses valeurs
dekel madame merkel vient de parler
était la liberté les droits de l'homme
les médias libres et bien sûr le marché
libre commun oc est aussi appartenir à
cette famille pour lesquelles ces
valeurs sont des piliers l'espagne et
moi je vais quand même malgré la
situation difficile que nous avons on en
crée en pologne mais aussi il ya les
partis de la même couleur en allemagne
afp n'est ce pas en france en italie à
peu près partout que nous devons
vraiment horizontalement les démocrates
d'europe entier entier unissez vous
aimez nous battre vraiment pour wii pour
ses valeurs mêmes qui nous unissent et
se tourner vers l'avenir mais là on voit
encore qu'au sein des dirigeants au pain
il ya des désaccords notamment entre
angela merkel emmanuel macron sur un
éventuel élargissement à l'albanie et à
la macédoine
est-ce qu'il faut continuer
l'élargissement et à je crois que la
vanille et la north masse et demi en
vraiment fait beaucoup de progrès et on
veut en transformer beaucoup pour être
dans l'union européenne et je crois que
cette région là est vraiment pas stable
et je crois qu'avec élargissement on va
garantir de la stabilité dans cette
région à région là et je crois que c'est
pour ça que c'est vraiment important de
continuer cette route là mais en même
temps on doit réformer l'union
européenne parce que si on ne peut pas
agir parce qu'on est trop il y en a pas
vraiment et à la capacité d'agir c'est
aussi un problème je suis d'accord mais
à 100% avec ce que vous venez de dire
parce que nous nous
nous faisons face aujourd'hui à deux
dangers premièrement une déstabilisation
des balkans occidentaux s'ils n'entrent
pas dans l'union européenne c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce danger existe
mais d'un autre côté si nous continuons
à élargir avant d'avoir réformé le
fonctionnement actuel de l'union
européenne
nous risquons à un blocage de l'union
européenne alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut
choisir comme danger je dirais que je
préfère c'est horrible à dire sessini
mais je préfère des dangers pesant sur
une région de l'europe ou de la future
union européenne qu un danger pesant sur
la totalité de l'union donc il faut
aller vite pour réformer l'union
européenne pour la faire évoluer
au moins pour donner l'impulsion de ce
changement et ensuite on pourra
reprendre le processus d'élargissement
rosenvallon sûr avec vous à est ce que
vous êtes d'accord
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas sûr parce
que réformer l'union européenne
c'est un processus qui dure tout le
temps il faut la réformer tout le temps
tu ne sais pas le nombre a changé ça ne
va pas se passer rapidement on va
surtout avec les tendances populistes
que nous avons maintenant dans l'union
européenne et élargir en ce moment on
parle on parle de deux exclusions un
petit pays qui ne vont pas tellement
peser sur l'union européenne mais
l'union veto c'est vrai qu'il faut
réformer ce système de oui mais ils vont
le réformer aussi par unanimité
et bien non nous n'avons pas cette
unanimité en ce moment dans l'union moi
je vous propose une formule de compromis
il faut réellement impulser des
changements d'importance dans l'union
européenne avant de reprendre le
processus d'élargissement les jeunes des
listes
ce pas de tapage quinzaine d'années dans
l'union parce qu'ils font des relevés
départ une année d'affilée la macédoine
albanie où je trouve qu'il faut vraiment
travailler là dessus de l'europe très
sérieusement et l'europe doit s'élargir
régulièrement et j'espère qu'ils vont
amener un impulse positif est pas
négatif pourquoi on craint dès le début
qu'ils vont faire l'événement
moi je crois que c'était vraiment une
horreur de président mac ronde à me
prendre cette édition-là et de dire non
en ce moment là à la macédonie moi je
crois que c'était vraiment l'effort et
non il n'a pas dit non il a dit pas tout
je crois qu'on a conduit les paysans
c'est moi les mots de la fin merci à
vous froisser la fin de cette émission
vous pouvez la voir en replay sur les
sites internet des chaînes
parlementaires mais aussi sur l'antenne
de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes
[Musique]